first thing you get asked explain why a
OC is 2x now just just as a note right
they don't give you a construction right
OC is not on there right that's kind of
a cool right it's well not just a CUDA
drawer but that once you draw it it will
form a critical part of like your
subsequent steps okay so watch as I put
it in there's a C okay so they're given
to you that it's 2x and of course the
reason is the center is twice the angle
at the circumference standing on the
same arc okay
arc AC so that's all fine that's easy
you look at the next part prove that a
CD or a C D is a cyclic quadrilateral
okay now remember I told you youth when
they make you put a construction it on
it's a big deal I could have just drawn
it on the diagram right but they made
you draw really okay what's the easiest
way this is to max right just follow
that away you know in a multi-part
question like this they really want you
to get it right they're not asking you
to show that that's 2x because it is and
that's nice and random it's because this
will form a critical matter dynamics
proof this is X what's this angle over
here also X because it's a it's a
necessity triangle so you've got an
equal angles opposite equal sides so
that's good
now if these two are both X then you can
see that this guy over here is 2x reason
Xterra ain't got a triangle is equal to
the sum of the opposite interior angles
that pause for a second pause why did I
go of all reasons of all things why did
I go straight there well they gave me a
2x so I'm looking for angles that are 2x
right and there aren't that maybe
them really right once you can see that
which is like it's an isosceles triangle
it's trying to slap you in the face
right that's the most obvious place when
you find two x okay now look look this
thing is meant to be this is meant to be
a cyclic one right so in theory and I
did a better job on my piece of paper
because I actually constructed Lethe but
in theory I should be able to have a
circle like okay now once you can see
that I'm trying to prove that this is
you know another way of saying that a CD
or is a cyclic quadrilateral is to say
that AC D and are the points con cyclic
just like you can say no lines of
concurrent meeting they go through the
same thing so these are inside kick
they're on the same circle okay so focus
on these two angles the two x's right do
you see that they are angles standing on
the same ah except that's the big arc
the arc
I'm interested in in this one right
because this is new smaller circle so
have you shown it they're both 2x all I
have to say is I'm just gonna my Bevin
you can hey DC is equal to a OC I've
just proved it okay and since they are
equal then D and Earth are on the
circumference as the same circle that
has a chord a you see do you see it
you're used to going in the other
direction you used to see okay I have AC
so therefore these are equal but it's a
converse right remember I said the vast
majority of property is Cynthia and she
looked at how all the converse is true
and I had to give you a counter example
so if you have this it implies that I am
in a circle are you with me so far
okay so I have my cyclic quadrilateral
what do they ask us to prove next okay I
can't serve yes
sir by proving R&D and cyclic you does
that automatically mean that the whole
thing I proved that oh and D are the
points on the circumference standing
with the angles that are equal standing
on the same park right so I've got a
circumference and an arc at the same
time which is why all four have to be a
concern because all right last step No
okay now so again they're requiring you
to construct something so they tell you
about these points right number one is M
okay which is the midpoint so I've got
bang bang bang bang of AC okay I've
already got over there now where is P P
is the center of this circle here now
again I actually constructed this thing
so it should be somewhere about roughly
okay you get Sona sitri
so what they asked us to prove is this
they want us to prove that MP urn or
p.m. and ER ah
kirlyam right what a straight line so
how do you do it they give you a big
clue by telling you what M is M is the
midpoint right and the midpoint now have
a look at how I've drawn this by the way
I've proved anything yet but look at
this line that apparently is a straight
line okay how do you think this relates
to and and the chord that it's on what
does it look like it looks it looks
perpendicular doesn't it and that's
because it is perpendicular but why why
is it perpendicular
okay so now be careful you may even need
to refer back to that little sheet I
gave you there were four I think as I've
three or four properties that all seem
like they're the same property but
reworded okay so here's an example here
we go lime from the center here's one of
them Y from the center that is
perpendicular to a chord bisects the
chord that's one of the versions right
another version is
lying from the center that bisects the
chord is perpendicular right so you see
that that's in Reverse okay now in
Reverse to both of those is if you have
a chord and you have a perpendicular
bisector
Rimma hobby started line from the center
blah blah blah blah right so this stops
from the other end so if you've got the
perpendicular bisector it must be a line
from the center does that make sense you
see how I assumed the line from the
center for these two that gives me
properties so here if I assume something
else that gives me that it goes through
the center sir watch AC and you can see
it on my construction a DC is a chord in
the original circle the big one and a
chord is a little circle the one I've
just drawn in green right yes
so therefore the line from the center
that's I'm sorry the line is
perpendicular here the perpendicular
bisector it must pass through P because
P is the center of the small circle and
the same line the perpendicular bisector
must pass through oh because it's the
center oh this guy the big one so the
way I word in it and I'll show you all
my reasons now so you can get it down
with your life because the wording is
kind of a bit so I said AC is a chord in
both circles ABC that's the big guy and
a CD oh that's the one we proved in part
to the perpendicular bisector of AC
which comes from M because M is the
midpoint right the perpendicular
bisector it should pass through the
center of this big circle that's all but
it should also because it's according a
little circle to that perpendicular
bisector should also pass through P
which is the center of that circle so if
the same line passes through two points
then all three of those points are on
one line right P and and a
so the reason that this is a bit tricky
is because as I said you're used to
going from you know doing things like
it's a circle therefore angles and twice
they ask you in the opposite direction
they say angles therefore circle right
perpendicular bisector therefore passes
through the center